on march 18th hogwarts legacy community
manager chandler wood answered the
following question on twitter where is
the angry tree aka whomping willow is
the secret passage to honeydukes going
to be included you should keep in mind
the official website shows what appears
to be a whopping willow-like tree here
and it also appears in an official
wallpaper released for the game and this
makes chandler's response even more
interesting because he said the whomping
willow wasn't planted until 1971. our
game takes place about 80 years before
that i can't confirm or deny specific
secret passages but i can say that the
world is filled with secrets mysteries
and nods to plenty of wizarding world
lore okay we definitely have to talk
about that second part on secret
passages but regarding the whomping
willow of course potter fans will know
that wood is absolutely correct here
with his timing on the whopping willow
we know from the original series in
harry potter and the prisoner of azkaban
remus lupin tells harry i told you
months ago that the whomping willow was
planted the year i came to hogwarts the
truth is that it was planted because i
came to hogwarts so what does wood's
response and what we know about the
whomping willow mean for the tree still
pictured on the hogwarts legacy website
i see only two possibilities here the
first is the tree we see pictured here
isn't actually a whomping willow at all
and honestly this is entirely possible
danny allen is a dev who worked on the
game and he actually responded to a
twitter question all the way back in
june of 2021 saying here we know better
than to use that but even though this is
completely possible i actually don't
think it's probable i do expect us to
come across a whomping willow in the
game first let's take a closer look at
some of the artwork avalanche shared in
the developer behind the scenes
interview and you'll find even more
trees that look similar to a whomping
willow i'm not saying they're all for
sure a whomping willow type tree but
some of them definitely look pretty
close you see while as harry potter fans
we often think of it as the whomping
willow because of its significance in
the original series it's actually just a
normal magical plant at least normal for
the wizarding world that is which means
there could be plenty of other whomping
willows out there in fact some of them
could even be very near hogwarts and
even in parts of the forbidden forest
we've never seen before avalanche talks
a lot about venturing beyond the walls
of hogwarts and exploring the
surrounding countryside so personally i
still expect we'll come across one or
two throughout the game it just won't be
the exact whomping willow we remember
from the days of lupin so i still
believe the tree we see pictured on the
website and some of the trees in this
artwork could be a whopping willow that
we'll see in the game i think a tree
that physically attacks and defends its
territory just lends itself so well to a
video game there are all sorts of
gameplay scenarios they could frame
around this whether it's a magical
creature who is maybe trapped near one
and needs rescuing or even one that's
protecting some sort of magical artifact
or who knows in a nod to the original
series maybe even something protecting a
secret passage i mentioned we also need
to talk about wood's response regarding
secret passages and this is absolutely
music to the ears of long time fans i
mean he didn't outright confirm secret
passages but he kind of did right
hogwarts contained so many secrets we
know even dumbledore admitted that he
didn't know all of them and considering
the school was made by two incredibly
powerful witches and two ridiculously
powerful wizards it all makes sense they
likely even kept many secrets from one
another about the castle and honestly
this is an area where avalanche can
really let their creativity shine
through because of how much freedom
there is to do something new and then
balance that with the familiar locations
that we all already know and love within
hogwarts when it comes specifically to
secret passages there are a few we know
about already that have a chance to be
in the game there's the one-eyed witch
statue which led to honeydukes a statue
of gregory the smarmy that leads
somewhere outside of hogwarts a mirror
on the fourth floor that led to
hogsmeade plus three others that fred
and george say they don't use because
filch already knows about them of course
this is all many years later in harry
potter's day the borgin and burke's
vanishing cabinets are another
possibility as they could have been
functional in this time period but we
don't know the exact date of their
creation and then there's also the
secret passage that was guarded by the
whomping willow that led to the
shrieking shack but of course neither
the whomping willow nor the shrieking
shack will be there in 1890. so this
question on the whomping willow is
actually just one of many questions i
still have about hogwarts legacy in fact
there are seven big questions we still
don't know the answer to and i have a
full video exploring those which you can
see on the right side of your screen now
as always thank you all so much for
watching i'll talk to you again soon